alors que depuis la semaine dernière l
annonce du président de la république
emmanuel macron d'un couvre-feu
généralisée toutes les décisions que
nous avons prises
c'est en effet un couvre-feu et
l'annoncent de jean castex ir qui a
étendu la mesure à d'autres départements
dont la polynésie française cette
progression de l'épidémie nous conduit à
étendre les mesures de couvre-feu à 38
nouveaux départements et à un territoire
d'outre-mer la polynésie ce sont près de
46 millions de français qui sont censés
rentrer chez eux avant 21h mais pourtant
de nombreuses incivilités ont été
recensés ile-de-france et 54
départements sont concernés par ce
couvre-feu
sauf que tout le monde ne l'entend pas
de cette oreille d'après les premiers
chiffres communiqués ce mardi
déjà plus de 3000 contravention avait
été dressée lors des dix-neuf mille
contrôles réalisés par les forces de
l'ordre
en seulement trois jours ce qui prouve
que à la fois la police et la
gendarmerie elle a remercié les forces
de l'ordre des contrevenants qui
s'exposent à 135 euros d'amande au
risque d'une contravention de 3750 euros
ainsi que six mois de prison en cas de
double récidive
à savoir trois infractions successives
de violation du couvre-feu
les mesures extrêmes qui ne semble
pourtant pas faire peur aux milliers de
français qui outrepasse les injonctions
du gouvernement
alors les français qui ne respectent pas
le couvre-feu choqué
allez c'est le coup de gueule n'a
vraiment que pensez vous de ces français
qui ne respectent pas le couvre-feu oui
vous avez ou prendre car fait alors
magali d'abord qui a l'air de alors moi
je suis pas choqué par je pense que
alors on va pas revenir sur le fait que
c'est un couvre-feu que c'est important
qu'il faut le respecter ya pas de soucis
mais je peux comprendre les français qui
ne sont pas contents qu'ils ne le
respecte pas pourquoi parce que pourquoi
comment on peut expliquer que par
exemple on prend une ville comme
marseille ils ont mis en place un
couvre-feu
il ya une semaine d'accord à cannes
c'est à une heure et demie y'a pas de
couvre feu donc les marseillais moi j
étais parce que j'ai mes enfants qui
sont dans le sud donc je suis allé là
bas pour ça j'ai vu tous les marseillais
à cannes
et quand on voit les commerçants de
cannes les restaurateurs de marseille
par dont six ferme qui sont pris à la
gorge quitte en rentrant dépression
parce que faux pas on sait les causes
d'une france qui se passe au coronavirus
les conséquences
mais les conséquences aussi aussi
financières pour les restaurateurs etc
ça fait rentrer des gens dépression on
va il ya des drames il ya des drames
d'accord pourquoi à une heure et demie
je dois travailler et l'autre là bas il
n'a pas le droit de travailler
donc on peut comprendre que les gens ils
ont les boules en fait alors si toi tu
sais ma santé passe avant les rues
management
attention la santé morale c'est aussi
très grave tu sais avoir un restaurant
ont pêché travailler et savoir qu'à 1h30
de chez toi oui tu as le droit travail
et je ne parle pas du coup on veut tu
peux comprendre que les gens ils sont en
crise de nerfs et que c'est long mais
les français subventions aujourd'hui non
mais je suis d'accord mais tu vois par
exemple moi qui suis à saint-jean-de-luz
qu'un jouera entre le week-end
la semaine dernière tout le monde est
descendu parce que le couvre-feu n'était
pas fait partout je pense que le
couvre-feu
il faut le mettre partout n'est d'accord
et oui je pense que on en sait tellement
nouveauté ce virus en mettant sur le dos
du gouvernement
c'est quelque chose de nouveau donc s'il
ya des règles faisons le verra dans dix
ans il attendait attendait nicolas
copernic sommes je crois que vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec magali comme
d'habitude c'est pas ça c'est que la
question c'est les français qui ne
respectent pas le rire fait choqué ou
non à la wii jeux game show alors oui
bien c est une mesure de protection pour
nos parents sont nos vieux pour nos amis
quand vous parlez souffrance des
restaurateurs moi je vais vous dire un
truc j'en ai ras-le-bol dont on ne
parlait que des restaurateurs suis chef
d'entreprise chez 60 salariés je viens
de faire un bilan social bats toi aussi
tout le monde souffre les gens qui sont
autour de nous tout le monde souffre on
souffre de papou avoir nos vieux nos
parents nos enfants je préfère que vous
étiez anciens
on peut dire que moi même je me sens un
peu conservez donc oui je vous vois le
terme le jeu est très positif et puis je
prendre vos nouvelles trois fois par
semaine vous pouvez pas manger le cog
juste une chose juste une chose c'est
que tout le monde souffre on n'a jamais
vécu ça moi j'ai 50 ans aujourd'hui
notre génération n'a jamais vécu une
pâte à l'us arize sanitaire avec plein
d'incohérences
on va parler des incohérences
aujourd'hui je veux dire que quand on
est président de la république ou chefs
de guerre il faut bien qu'il ya un mec
qui prennent des décisions sur nous et
qu'on le suive
sinon un moment donné si tout le monde
tient que des sachants aujourd'hui c'est
que des gens qui donnent leur avis sur
tha n'a que des médecins partout daniel
moreau si un mois pourtant vous le savez
je ne suis pas une rebelle est pas si je
suis chez des rebelles je suis choqué
quand je vois ces rébellions dans la rue
parce que voilà mais en revanche j'ai
quand même mis entre le oui et le non
parce que je donne un exemple précis
en fait on nous fait des contraintes le
gouvernement nous fait des contraintes
mais ne laissez pas d'arranger les
choses derrière puisque regarder on doit
donc à paris c'est que c'est évidemment
un problème plutôt parisien rentrée à
21h il paraît qu'à 20h30
il ya les métros sont bondées parce que
tout le monde rentre en même temps donc
soit on fait un couvre feu mais on
organise leur peu de choses pour le
fasse c'est pas juste de dire ça voyez
par exemple sur les rangs comme le dit
on dit toujours on dit toujours on ferme
les restaurants fermés match 1 où le
couvre feu etc
mais dans des transports publics tout le
monde porte un masque dans les
restaurants qui ne portent pas sinon
josé le métro mais surtout se battre au
nez les transports sud n'est pas précis
il faut quand même vous avez mauvaise
vie
vous aimez je suis trois meurent dans
les transports par jour métro bus rer a
mais j'ai l'épilation on le sait vous
regarder rapidement on a l'impression
tout le monde menace les jours l'enlève
pour téléphoner alors que c'est le
moment où ils font le plus de postillons
je suis allé mais tout ce mal le masque
je vous comprend daniel je vous vous
êtes québec et bien je voudrais à la
danse vous faire la distinction entre
s'cusez moi l'expression mais tous les
connards qui effectivement ne respecte
pas qu'ils vont aider à cet homme là
c'est une mise en danger je suis
d'accord pour les gens lambda qui
travaillent au quotidien il ya les
restaurateurs il ya d'autres corps de
métiers et jean-marc complètement
concret je vous raconte pas les chaises
ne l'aimé pas loupé ma coiffeuse et qui
j'étais fière qui au bord au bord de la
faillite parce que par exemple elle
m'explique une clientèle jeune coiffeuse
ou quand je vois la toussaint peu la
touffe
voilà un peu épaisse au dessus vous
inquiétez pas je vais battre le colorant
et elle m'expliquait un truc
complètement contre l as concernant ces
cas mêmes clients qui arrivent à 19
heures il n'y a pas encore de couvre-feu
pour une couleur une couleur c'est
beaucoup d'argent pour elle est l'objet
de la refuser parce qu'une couleur ça
dure trois heures 4 heures je sais pas
combien de temps et aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'un couvre-feu à 21h en réalité
il faut anticiper tout ça le temps que
les gens rentrent et c'est l'économie
s'arrête ne sape à 21h mais ça va être
beaucoup plus tôt et aujourd'hui il faut
arrêter d'être jouer les faux culs la
solidarité de départ aujourd'hui c'est
tout le monde qui veut sauver son qu
économiquement l'économie oui a pris le
dessus aujourd'hui j'ai péché désolé
c'est une réalité non mais je hais les
incohérences est ce que tu as fait six
ils viennent et qui sont réelles
regardez ce au 20 heures de france 2
hier soir justement des personnes qui
sont province ne comprenait pas au fin
fond de l'aveyron mais pourquoi un
couvre-feu par ici cela il faut une
cohérence nationale
peut-être qu'à des clusters silence des
mois mais oui ma gueule ou quoi aussi
par exemple on laisse les centres
commerciaux ouverts avec une tonne de
personnes à l'intérieur et une salle de
sport avec 20 personnes
on la ferme c'est ça qui met le feu et
c'est ça qui vous met les gens
aujourd'hui ne respecte plus rien parce
que les règles sont incohérentes que
tout sera prêt à l'identité nationale
donc non je ne suis pas choqué parce que
tout est incohérent et que du coup bah
on ne respecte plus rien donc je
comprends les français qui ne
respecteraient le ménage rganisée comme
ça non mais ça me navre magali avec tout
l'amour que j'ai pour toi ça me navre
des 10 points comme ça parce que dès ton
discours est très dangereux surtout par
les temps qui courent te dirai qu'on
respecte rien donc c'est l'anarchie et
on fait ce qu'on veut
sont divines chéri écoute la question
est vous êtes choqués ou pas c'est pas
est ce que le gouvernement eut raison
c'est pas pour autant que je suis moi
pour le couvre feu
je suis désolé les mêmes crétins qu'on
va dans la rue c'était les joggeurs qui
voulait courir tous les jours qu'on voit
plus nulle part plus personne n'a envie
de faire de sport les mêmes qu'avant
vite dessiné au bord de la seine à
l'époque du consul mans parce qu'ils
étaient tous des picasso du dimanche
également il faut arrêter à un moment
donné il ya des règles les respecte et
le problème notre gouvernement sait
qu'ils sont tellement laxiste ou une
petite contraventions par six mecs faut
télé en taule foot et lors de la garde à
vue tous eux quand ils manifestent dans
les rues sont plaints de sauver leur taf
ils sont à leur bureau en train de
travailler sont en train de dd les vieux
ils font rien que foutent la merde
renversé des poubelles aller faire les
cons dans la rue faut arrêter ça il sait
rien
[Applaudissements]
c'est que ce soit plus 21h le court au
cdis mais une entreprise je vais vous
dire quand vous avez salariés qui ont
une heure et demie c'est la mort du
travail et mairie attention à ce genre
de propos est sur les mêmes tout le
monde sait ce que je vous réponde aux
standards ce soit en magasin sont pas
les mêmes pour tout le monde
soit tu confine toute la france échoue à
21h sacem confine à la moitié la france
est pas les élites tu peux pas empêcher
les gens travaillaient ici je suis
désolé on respecte pas je sens même
temps j'ai dit je vais donner mon 100
millions je ne sais pas choquer je
t'adore mais là pour le coup je déplace
le problème est autre part la question
c'est les français qui ne respectaient
pas le couvre-feu est ce que vous êtes
choqués politiquement correct sinon
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
tout triste parce que moi je suis désolé
ma grand mère elle a 90 ans et 6 mois un
seuil à la 96ème ma grand mère je
souhaite si jma est d'avoir la main 3
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
leurs excuses à cette 87e tous ces trous
du cul là c'est bien ma ma liberté
mais ta liberté quant au fond du filet
pour les écoles du patronat mme jetté
on ne demande pas aux passagers où la
météo et twilight qu'antenne de
branquignols là qu'ils se promenaient
dans paris ont versé des poubelles ont
lors ils sont pas quoi faire ils ont pas
restaurateur non c'est juste des trous
du cul là qui ont fait leurs preuves et
la solide parler tous en même temps
pardonnez moi je ne parle pas de cela je
ne pas pas des gens qui font exprès pour
la rébellion débit je ne parle pas de ça
je parle de la majorité des français qui
souffrent aussi
mais tu peux se mettre à leur place et
qui n'ont pas le choix aujourd'hui il ya
des gens qui calibre alors qu'est ce
qu'elle fait déjà dit dans ces cas
qu'est ce qu'on fait je te démerdes
confie tout le monde et on met tout le
monde au même niveau on arrête de faire
des différences
j'essaie d'aider les rayons mais ça veut
dire quoi l'après midi tu peux tomber
malade pendant que tu vas faire les
boutiques tu as balles et des armes et
le soin que ton plus malades
non je suis désolé soins consignes c'est
vrai que c'est pas les boutiques
désolé c'est très grave de laisser les
magasins et les centres commerciaux
ouverts et par contre resteront fermés
pourquoi fermer tout restons chez nous
pendant quinze jours du wef mais danois
souffre menacer mais choisit les
bâtiments qui on va enterrer
excusez moi je vais prendre une
camomille avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors alors vraiment je sais que c'est
un sujet qui est très fort ici tout le
monde
mais rappelez-vous si le confinement qui
a été très violent pour tout le monde
les personnes isolées pendant deux mois
tout seul vialis donc les solidarités à
ce moment là où tout le monde faisait la
même chose donc on est content ni
gagnant aussi les soignants et amédée
tout le monde il faut penser à tous ces
gens le gouvernement